welcome ghosts and ghouls to October top
5 every week this month will feature a
Halloween themed countdown starting
today with the best of a show that gave
us all goosebumps this was a series that
introduced a horror genre to a lot of
people at a very young age
goosebumps was a series that aired from
1995 to 1998 which spanned four seasons
and 74 episodes it was based on the very
popular book series of the same name by
creator and author RL Stein every week a
new story would be told that was adapted
from one of his books these creepy tales
opened our imagination scared the crap
out of us and had us all questioning the
pronunciation of house this series was
produced in Canada and continues to
connect with kids all over the world
every episode is currently on Netflix
and iTunes in addition to a popular
feature film hitting theaters in 2015
with the sequel planned for next year
everyone has a few favorite goosebumps
episodes I'm here today to present you
with mine these are the top 5 best
episodes of goosebumps number 5 Night of
the Living dummy 2 from season 1 if you
watched or read goosebumps growing up
you know who slappy the evil dummy is
this was his first time on screen and it
was definitely an unforgettable
appearance amy is a young girl who
receives a ventriloquist dummy as a gift
from her father while she loves him at
first
slappy soon starts to exhibit tendencies
that suggests he has a mind of his own
with her family not believing her amy is
the only one who can stop slappy if I'm
hurting the ones she holds dear if
there's one character that stands out as
the most recognizable in the Goosebumps
series its slappy
he's been the unofficial face of the
series for years and this episode
introduced him to a lot of fans
he's always brought to life by the
reading of these words Carol Mary
Karen oh they do a good job in this
episode of building the tension and
making slappy out to be creepy before we
see him walk on his own in the climax
you also feel sympathy for Amy as she is
blamed for all the mayhem slappy causes
around the house when everything finally
hits the fan it's a pretty good payoff
[Music]
spoilers for the ending just in case
when slappy is finally taken down and we
see who was responsible it's a fun
little twist it's good to be back to the
family again it's too bad we didn't see
Dennis in any future episodes that
featured slappy he could have been a fun
rival for him what are you looking at
dummy number four the ghost next door
from season four and if all the episodes
listed here I think this one is the
least well-known but it might be the
most complete story
Hannah lives in a large house in a
normal town but when a boy named Danny
moves in next door with his family she
starts suspecting something very odd
about him and the house he lives it to
talk about this one for too long will
give away why I like it so much
how expectations are thwarted in both
parts of the story we're not things I
saw coming they do cheat a little bit
but as the story moves into part two it
gets even better with a very clever
setup the characters all really feel
like they have strong reasons for what
they're doing give this one a rewatch I
think it's a forgotten classic and
should be recognized more when we look
back at the series let me know what you
think of this episode and the comments
below number three
one day at HorrorLand from season three
horror land happens to be my favorite
goosebumps book so it's only natural
that this two-parter made it into the
top 5 the Morrises are a family who get
lost on their way to Zoo Gardens theme
park when they come across a different
strange theme park named horror land
they decide to check it out and enjoy
the day there however what they don't
realize is that horror land more than
lives up to its name I really like this
store parts 1 & 2 are completely
different which makes it unique and
memorable part 1 builds up the mystery
of what's really going on in horror land
it actually has a few head-turning
scares
sharp turns no talking
for whatever reason I remember this
monster punch seen very clearly since I
first saw part two is completely
different it's mostly just played up for
a joke but the jokes are actually pretty
funny all right we have some lovely
snacks here you do to partake I have
Doyle ear of Holyfield some of my
favorite parts are the monster
commercials now over the first time on
one CD greatest monster love songs
you'll get your heart is in my pocket
and your lips are in my drawer and get
in the mood with ward toward also the
horror that helps them in part two is
hilarious welcome back to rowdy that
works you should have been yeah the
sequel to the goosebumps movie is also
going to be titled Goosebumps HorrorLand
so this is definitely one of the more
long-lasting stories from the original
run two spots left
number two the Haunted mask from season
one the Haunted mask is another one of
those episodes that has seemed to stick
with the kids who watched it as we've
gotten older
Carly Beth is a girl who is pretty much
afraid of everything her classmates
constantly exploit her fear which leaves
her angry frustrated and wanting revenge
when she tries to go out and buy a scary
mask to get back at two boys in
particular she picks out an
exceptionally terrifying one that the
shopkeeper says isn't for sale she ends
up stealing the mask and while indeed
scary it attaches itself to her face and
slowly changes her personality this
story is a classic that I think holds up
very well 24 years after it was first
written there's a ton I could go into
about how well this premise works as a
scary concept for kids
however it's not without its flaws the
girl playing Carly Beth is really
playing up her wimpy persona almost too
much in a few scenes she gets much
better later but I mean
yeah the backstory on the shopkeeper as
the creator of the masks is pretty
interesting this spooky tale is very
smart and how everything is connected I
was the man who created these faces
Carly Beth I was like you I did not love
myself once Carly Beth puts on the mask
it makes for some really strong scenes
the fact that she carries around her own
sculpted head on a stick is the perfect
touch and the head looks so real where'd
you get it oh it's me it's who I used to
be used to be forget it all so that
thing in itself is creepy as hell later
talked okay so the effect isn't great by
today's standards but I can look past
that for how good of a Halloween story
the Haunted mask is the first two
episodes of the Goosebumps series still
hold up as some of its best
this series offered much more than just
five great episodes so before we get to
number one here are a few horrifying
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best goosebumps
episode is the Haunted mask - from
season 2 I think this two-parter matched
and outdid the original while perfectly
balancing three perspectives Steve one
of the bullies from the original Haunted
mask story takes one of the evil masks
left in the same now closed-down
Halloween shop Carly Beth got hers from
the year prior his mask starts to turn
him into a decaying old man
while the original mask possesses the
shopkeeper and tries to take revenge on
Carly Beth for abandoning it the
previous Halloween sitting down to watch
this and the original back to back is
the perfect Halloween night goosebumps
experience this sequel works so well
it's not a retread or step backward for
Carly Beth as she has now become a much
stronger character after she went
through what she did the year before
instead one of the kids who bullied her
in the previous installment takes
Carly's place as someone who takes and
wears one of the shopkeepers masks Steve
turning into an old man after wearing
the mask for so long is a great choice
it plays on the universal fear of
getting too old before you've had the
chance to live
[Music]
[Applause]
the original mask ends up being the true
villain of the story as it uses both the
shopkeeper and Steve to try and get
Carly Beth back under its power
[Music]
now
your eyes will see shall I sing things
from the perspective of Steve Carly Beth
and the Haunted mask made for a great
sequel that added depth to this overall
story it's definitely number one in my
book the goosebumps brand has
undisputedly endured over the years with
the success of the feature film a couple
of years ago we can safely assume that
aural steins chilling children's stories
won't be going anywhere anytime soon so
continue to be where you are still in
for a scare I want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite goosebumps
episode what do you want me to cover
next in the show leave a comment and let
me know for more content subscribe to my
personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome Walter like my facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome Walter B and
follow along on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week
as we take a look at the episodes that
didn't quite work as well as these
[Applause]
[Music]
you